hey youtubers is Charlie so this year at
WonderCon Andrew Kreisberg confirmed
that we would be getting near master in
season two he just you know one of the
many rogues that we haven't seen yet so
you know just a matter of them working
down the list just like there are a
couple versions of the trickster in the
comics there are a couple versions of
mirror master the first one was named
Sam Scudder then during the mid-90s
wally west era evan mccullough took the
mantle but you know although that
character appeared for the first time in
animal man's comic book in 1989 he was
created by Grant Morrison of all people
who actually did go on to work on the
main flash title with Mark Millar no
less but that was until like way later
in 2009 during the new 52 reboot that
you know they retcon things and Sam
Scudder became the main mirror master
again in there of course you know a
couple different alternate universe
version of the character too there's one
that was part of the renegades that the
25th century version of the roads that
weren't actually villains they were
actually heroes in the future there was
also a flashpoint version that was just
a little bit different really though
it's the Sam Scudder and Evan McCullough
versions those are the two main versions
so season two of the flash might have a
little bit of fun with the mirror master
character the same way it had fun with a
trickster character although I'm not
expecting to do the exact same thing
it's just that you know Mark Hamill
played the trickster the original
trickster on the original flash show
came on the news show playing the old
character from the original show then
they brought on the alternate axle
version of the trickster from the comics
you know just ain't played with that
just had a little bit of fun in defense
of originality you know I'm not
expecting them to just recycle old
tropes that they did from season one
just recycle plot lines so I'll probably
just go with one version of mirror
master and then just include a bunch of
Easter eggs for the other versions
although it should come as no surprise
that the original flash TV show the John
Wesley Shipp show did a version of mere
master David Cassidy of all people
big surprised played Sam Scudder he
played you know the original version of
the trickster
so I mean he could come on flash season
two but I'm not expecting it David
Cassidy is no Mark Hamill you know Mark
Hamill is like a special case you also
have to remember that the writers
whenever they're creating characters for
this show tend to draw from Jeff John's
run and that's the Evan McCullough
version of the character but they do
tend to go with the original versions in
terms of names like Digg or Hartness
Captain Boomerang so what they might do
is go with a Sam Scudder name
with an Evan McCullough characterization
the new 52 version is the Sam Scudder
but they turned him into a metahuman DC
is going through like a big redesign
post convergence but it remains to be
seen whether or not they're gonna change
the mirror master character again most
of the big changes they're making to
their comic books are to like the a-list
characters like they're taking away a
lot of Superman's powers Jim Gordon is
gonna be the new Batman wearing like a
big Batman mech suit you get the idea
you know mostly it's like the big
characters that are changing the most
for the most part you know across all
versions of the character mirror masters
powers revolve around access to the
mirror world the first version of the
character was obviously like a slightly
simpler version of that you know he just
he found a way to use mirrors to commit
crimes in the new 52 all the ropes have
the same types of powers they just they
became metahumans so they didn't require
as much gear the twist was is that like
as they became metahumans their powers
had really negative consequences like
really bad side effects mirror masters
was that he got trapped inside the
mirror world and couldn't leave
oh yeah although eventually he did find
a way there was a brief period where the
the digger Harkness Captain Boomerang
took the mantle of mirror master to
commit crimes behind the suicide squads
back do you know just so they wouldn't
find out but that was after the original
mirror master died so here's a quick
back story for the first mirror master
of Sam Scudder originally he was just a
regular ex-con working at a mirror
Factory he ended up messing a bunch of
chemicals up that they used to make the
mirrors and stumbled on what he called
the mirror world
he ended up discovering that the mirror
had a bunch of special properties and
used those to create effects to help him
commit crimes like the camera mirror a
little pocket-sized mirror he used it to
capture images of people then larger
mirrors to print 3d copies of those
people like mirror images of them that
he could control in his first issue what
he did is is he created a copy of a bank
teller to try and use it to rob a bank
the flash just happened to be at the
bank notice the Bakke teller look you
know looked like his hair had been
reversed as if it were a mirror image
followed him back to mirror masters
hideout and then defeated him the big
twist to mirror masters powers are that
he requires light for them to work so in
order to fight him the flash usually has
to smash mirrors or turn the lights off
later in flash number 130 mirror master
reveals he's learned how to use mirrors
to control people's minds and the second
mirror master
Evan McCullough use the mirror gun you
know then during new 52 they retcon that
plot point and Sam Scudder became the
person to create the technology but for
the most part Sam Scudder used like a
little hand mirror
Evan McCullough use the mirror gun the
gun itself works as an instant replay
device for for just about anything
anything that it witnesses it can turn
people into flat shards of glass and
reverse the process that's actually one
of his more dangerous attacks like if
the mirror gets smashed with the person
in it they'll die so they ended up
killing Sam Scudder off during crisis on
Infinite Earths they did that kind of
thing on the flash this season where
Captain Cold worked with the flash for
like a brief period till he
double-crossed him there been a lot of
times in the comics when the flash has
worked with the Rogues
against a bigger villain but usually the
Rogues always end up trying to
double-cross him in the end
Scudder had actually been part of this
team to try and stop Corona from looking
back to the dawn of time so so he and a
bunch of the people traveled to OA but
they died in this big booby trap in
Cronus lab so after he died that's when
the digger Harkness Captain Boomerang
took his gear and his name to commit
crimes behind the suicide squads back
eventually
Evan McCullough took the mantle so what
happened is is that the FBI came to Evan
McCulloch and gave him this Amanda
Waller Task Force X type pitch you know
help us out and we'll help with your
criminal record the deal was is that he
would take Sam Scudders gear become
mirror master pretend to be a
supervillain to take down other super
villains for the FBI as you'd expected
dirtbag to do he double-crossed the FBI
you know you just got tired of working
for him killed his handlers then joined
the Rogues and you know over time he's
slowly he tried to innovate a little bit
with Sam Scudders powers so they kind of
widened the scope of what he could do
with mirrors in the mirror world really
like the big evolution was is that he
learned to use his powers using any
reflective surface he didn't need just
mirrors and even though he was a
terrible person he was way more
sympathetic than the Sam Scudder version
of the character
he sends like a portion of his proceeds
his criminal proceeds to the orphanage
that raised him and he even tried to get
dr. light to stop raping women way back
during Final Crisis he and dr. light
teamed up to try and steal metrans
Mobius chair a bunch of female
superheroes got knocked out and miR
master was like hey you know radical
idea maybe we don't rape all these women
and we just take off with the chair but
fact about the Mobius chair - if you
guys haven't been reading it the
darkside war that's going on in justice
league right now Geoff Johns is writing
it there's this big connection between
the Mobius chair and the anti-monitor
so you should check that out it's pretty
cool just in terms of how you know like
the TV show might treat the mirror
master character no idea if he's gonna
be metahuman or if he's gonna use tech
the way the producers explained it
during season one like initially was
that the people that they turned into
metahumans were the ones that they felt
like logically couldn't create their own
technology of course now we know the
Caitlin and Cisco both metahumans and
they're totally capable of creating
their own tech so that logics out the
window so a mere master could go either
way metahuman not metahuman they'll be
teasing a whole bunch of stuff like that
when we get to comic-con you know but
just season two especially what's going
to be going on in the first couple of
episodes whenever the season picks up
next week I'm probably gonna be doing a
dr. alchemy video because he's another
villain that they've confirmed so be
sure to subscribe to get that if there
are any other characters you want me to
do videos for just let me know in the
comments what I'm gonna try and do this
summer is start doing like a flash arrow
Supergirl you know DC whatnot giveaway I
haven't completely figured out how
that's gonna work just be sure to watch
all the DC videos that I post for more
details I'm gonna be doing a new arrow
season 4 video tomorrow I know and I got
some guardians of the galaxy to stuff
that I want to do so look for that video
- James Gunn's just been dropping a lot
of details recently so why you guys wait
for all that stuff you can click here to
learn about how Batman is changing the
comics from decade to decade Arkham
Knight is coming really soon
int you can click here to learn all
about the women of Deadpool thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow